♪ ♪
>> Jesse: NORTH KOREA ISN'T
KNOWN FOR TREATING FOREIGNERS
WITH RESPECT.
DO YOU REMEMBER OTTO WARMBIER?
TWO PEOPLE BY SURPRISE WHEN
PEOPLE HEARD LESTER HOLT MAKING
APPOINTED CREDIT THE COUNTRY FOR
ITS KIND TREATMENT DURING HIS
VISIT.
>> WE ARRIVED IN NORTH KOREA ON
SATURDAY.
WE FLEW THE STATE AIRLINE.
IT'S ABOUT A ONE HOUR AND A HALF
FLIGHT FROM BEIJING.
WE HAVE BEEN INVITED.
OUR GUESTS, WE STAYED OUTSIDE
PYONGYANG.
OF NORTH KOREA THAT MOST
AMERICANS DON'T SEE AND
CERTAINLY A PARTS THEY WOULD
LIKE US TO SEE.
>> Jesse: DANA, DO YOU THINK
LESTER HOLT REALIZES HE IS
PROPAGANDA VICTORY.
>> Dana: I DO.
IN EACH REPORT HE HAS A LITTLE
BIT OF A CAVEAT.
WE GET THE JOKE.
I THINK THIS VIDEO AND THESE
INVITATIONS ARE NOT MEANT FOR
US.
THIS IS MEANT FOR INTERNAL
PROPAGANDA BRAINWASHING SO THAT
THE LEADER, THE DEAR LEADER, CAN
SHOW ALL THE PEOPLE THERE THEY
HOW WONDERFUL THEIR COUNTRIES.
MEANWHILE, MOST OF THE COUNTRY
IS STARVING AND IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
IN "THE WEEKLY STANDARD" CUP AND
ETHAN EPSTEIN WRITES A PIECE
CALLED "12 TIMES THE MEDIA
OFFERED A RARE GLIMPSE INTO
NORTH KOREA."
WE ARE BEING USED.
>> Jesse: IF YOU WERE LESTER.
PRETEND YOU ARE LESTER.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE INVITATION?
WEEK OF SHOWS IN NORTH KOREA.
COOKING WITH FRIENDS WOULD BE
LITERAL.
THE CASSEROLE LOOKS FAMILIAR.
THEY SHOWED AS PART OF
NORTH KOREA WE DON'T SEE, HE
SAID.
WE ONLY SEE WHAT THEY LETS US
SEE.
IT'S VERY COMMON AMONG COMMUNIST
LEADERS.
THEY DO THIS WITH HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES.
THEY WOULD INVITE -- THEY WOULD
GO TO CUBA, USSR, VENEZUELA.
TRAVELING MOUTHPIECES.
THEY WOULD TREAT YOU WELL.
THEY'LL GET YOU FOOD, WOMEN, ALL
SORTS OF STUFF.
BUT THERE'S INTERESTING THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN.
THE U.S. PROBABLY CANNOT
EXERCISE A MILITARY OPTION
KNOWING THOSE PEOPLE ARE THERE.
OR THEY COULD INFECT THEM WITH
SOME KIND OF BIOLOGICAL AGENT
AND SEND THEM BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES WHICH IS POSSIBLE.
>> Kimberly: DO YOU LAY AWAKE
AT NIGHT THINKING ABOUT THIS?
>> Greg: ALL THE TIME.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, WELL,
"THE FIVE" WILL NOT BE GOING TO
NORTH KOREA.
>> Kimberly: WE JUST ASKED TO
GO TO THE SUPER BOWL.
IT WAS GOOD.
LESTER HOLT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO THERE.
I GET IT AS A JOURNALIST.
I DON'T BEGRUDGE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT I THINK SOME OF
THE CRITICISM IS FAIR.
WE LOOK AT THE FACTS,
CIRCUMSTANCE, EVIDENCE, ENTAIL
COMING OF NORTH KOREA, YOU SEE
IT'S A BARBARIC ROGUE REGIME
WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING STARVED
THROUGH THE ARMY IS STARVING.
HE'S ON A CHARM CAMPAIGN
OFFENSIVE FOR THE OLYMPICS TO
TRY TO PROVE THERE IS SOMETHING
OTHER THAN WHAT THEY ARE.
THAT'S WHY HE'S SENDING DANCERS
IN THIS AND BACK TO THE OLYMPICS
IN THIS AND BACK TO THE OLYMPIC
OLYMPICS.
LET NOT YOUR MIND BE FOOLED.
A >> Jesse: ES, AND PART OF
THE TERM OFFENSIVE, THEY ARE
ATHLETES AND I THINK THE DEAR
LEADER SPENT ABOUT 35 MILLION
ON THIS SKI RESORT.
ALL PART OF THE PROPAGANDA.
>> Juan: ABSOLUTELY.
THE KEY POLITICAL POINT IS YOU
WILL HAVE 22 NORTH KOREAN
ATHLETES MARCHING WITH THE
SOUTH KOREAN DELEGATION INTO THE
OLYMPICS AND THIS IS A REAL SHOW
OF UNITY.
YOU HAVE MOON JAE-IN, THE
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY IN THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES AS
WE TRY TO PUT PRESSURE ON
NORTH KOREA.
THE SANCTIONS, AS KIMBERLY SAID,
ALL OF THAT STARTS TO FALL AND
BE UNCERTAIN.
I THINK PART OF IT IS TO HAVE
AMERICANS COME IN.
THEY HAVE HAD VICE COME IN,